all right
episode you're about to see with the
hilarious jessica kirsten we talk about
fat camp we talk about jenny craig we
talked about addiction it's honestly
it's talking about
only fans talk about only fans and it's
an amazing episode
of all time tbh so nice house very
rarely have guests in and she's the
perfect addition to hey babe she's what
sal and i would be
if we were women that's true
i'd say if we were women we'd be jessica
kearson uh and i'm happy with that happy
for that happy all about that she hasn't
had a piece of bread in six months
that's true yeah all right this weekend
saturday i'm in uh san diego on the 21st
i am in l.a at the wilton theater this
sunday the 22nd coming up and on sale
right now i got new dates i got vegas i
got phoenix boulder colorado syracuse no
that's yes syracuse is coming in june
seattle portland and
vancouver my first canadian date ever
right there there it is baby
savilecounty.com there it is and christy
comedy.com i'll be at in austin next
week um may 24th and then phoenix may
26th ticket's almost gone but christy
comedy.com and especially she out on
netflix right
now don't run away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe happy hey babe to you
happy hey babe to you
happy hey baby dear jessica
happy hey baby
hey jessica kirsten everybody
how are you
i'm i'm okay how are you i mean i'm not
bad we don't sing that every time it's
the first time we ever sang it it's a
it's the birthday song yes yes but it
was apropos sure guess we hadn't we
didn't think we think of a song for
today we usually substitute the words
hey babe into a song and we enter every
every uh episode singing and then
usually we have we prepare it but this
uh sal is dealing with a window issue
yeah yeah i'm kind of like
it's very lazy that you just put it into
the birthday song
i mean the suggestion was skip it or not
you know so we were just like we should
have been happy hey babe you're a jew
what
[Laughter]
could you imagine no hey babe it's like
a clean podcast matt look wednesday we
just start talking about it's not like
deeply political well i mean you know we
just don't talk about like graphics
not like we don't like stay away from he
started talking about we talk about it
but yeah i don't peg it as a clean yeah
no not clean i mean i don't know we
don't really talk about like i don't
know that's kind of dirty we just talk
about like fun things that are happening
in the world but maybe this episode
maybe we should well we could now
support russia who do you support
what
the good i support the nazis which which
are which team is the nazis
jessica kearson by the way one of the
funniest um comedians ever i when i
first started comedy um
i met jessica
and i uh
was in awe
of her and this other guy bernard
ferschmann
um
everything chris and sal says i laugh at
so that's what this is
the way you're butt nuts fish man the
way you just said that i remember
jessica jessica at one point a few years
ago like whatever 12 years ago used to
teach a comedy class and that's how i
got to meet jessica and she was like
would teach it and so powerful and then
i remember one time she got car trouble
or something happened with her children
and she couldn't make it and this guy
bernie first band who's like her
assistant manager just started getting
up and teaching the class he started
teaching the class and talking about how
you have to put comedy in boxes i was
like jessica doesn't jessica says speak
from your [ __ ] is that
you're literally just saying whatever
you want to say
bernie was the one don't put my glasses
on you're literally a four-year-old my
children do that but you can those are
reading what do you think i look like
they're cute on you yeah i would adjust
the frame slightly but honestly you
would look good with glasses you look
like i feel like anderson you're so
handsome both of you are so handsome
[Laughter]
yeah you looked really cute in those
glasses you tried them too they're
reading glasses
well first of all the way you just did
your eyes was insane but you look
adorable too that looks good in glasses
you both look really good you look good
jessica thank you you look fanta and you
said you haven't starving now you
haven't eaten a piece of bread in six
months no i'm starving i'm telling you
i'm very hungry when's the last time you
had pizza
oh my god honestly pizza a slice of
pizza and i'm gonna be honest because
you know what 30 a.m right so you had it
i got someone in the elevator on the way
up to the apartment i had a hike tonight
at 12 30 last night i had a white slice
it was a small one you did yeah i love
white pizzas great
i love it the only kind i'll eat is
white pizza
i know i i'm going to be honest the last
time i had a slice of pizza probably two
years ago wow yeah so what's cauliflower
pizza you have that no that was maybe a
year ago because cauliflower pizza's
even on that even that can right
that had flour in it but i i haven't had
that in a year don't know
is it like a flower and a glittery thing
or whatever it is no no i i don't eat
flour i don't need a lot of sugar
anymore not hardly any sugar i i'm a
food addict so i had to give up foods
you look great thank you
much lot of i mean you know i used to be
oh my god i so
a house this is the kind of thing where
people now you're a condo
now you're a townhouse
you're a pool house
now i'm now
cabana
i'm a mansion
that is the funniest thing i've heard in
a long time
i used two kids i used to be a mansion
and now yeah now i'm now i'm a tutor but
you have to feel like a different person
right
like i feel like a different person i do
i i do i say i lost a ton of weight i
keep some weight on so i don't get
assaulted yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i've gotten i've gotten some people
online some women are like you can still
get assaulted if you're heavy i'm like
not as much yeah you're not gonna
no because i i've been uh yeah i've been
assaulted and it has happens more when
you have yeah wow
there's stats like the stat sheet on the
salts per weight class
yeah
well homeless pimp has lost a bunch of
weight too and he almost depends on a
slice of pizza in a year either yeah not
one slice but you're two years he's
assaulted you guys yo he gets assaulted
you guys know me listen i get so [ __ ]
angry when people get upset when i talk
about my weight stuff i wait i know
330 pounds okay if i want to [ __ ]
talk about my weights right i was
enormous i was not okay right i was not
okay i was dying i was not when did you
weigh 3 30. how long ago you knew me i
mean this was like 12 years ago i mean i
was wow incredibly heavy if you google
me it i barely fit on the screen i was
[ __ ] enormous you never you never in
your life
thought that you could get to the weight
you're at now no i have been at the
weight i've been i'm at now like i in
college i was skinny i got skinny i went
on like jenny craig i lost a ton of
weight how's she doing i was this thin
i don't know i ate her
i was is she real i was a i was yes
she's i don't know if she's i've never
seen her
is she a real person she's transgender
her name's craig jenny now
wow jenny craig born jennifer
he's amazing
born genevieve gudros jennifer's good
luck she's like you have to weigh all
your food
she was born in 1932.
[Laughter]
craig was born in berwick louisiana
and married sydney craig in 1979.
craig
wait 32 that means she's 90. she must be
90 years old 90. she's the one on the
right in the green shirt oh her husband
sid chris birthday's coming up she's
going to be 90. well she's going to be
90. my grandma's 90.
it says age 89 ranch boy she made a
fortune oh my god
who
she might be the most well-known
weight loss person like jenny craig has
got to be more worth more money than
weight watchers person who do you think
has more money jenny craig or lucille
roberts who do you think jenny is lucia
roberts that's the gym
isn't that a wonderful that's a gym from
like the 80s no but i mean does that
exist lucille roberts net worth 30
million really wow and now generally
yeah her husband did
300 million
300 million i never tried a weight loss
song
they were programmed
but this is the thing i was an athletic
kid i was pretty thin but in a jewish
house if you're 10 pounds overweight
you're enormous you're fat so i went to
fat camp and then i got fatter every
year i you know camp is the real thing
yeah i went to fat campus
i talk about it on stage a lot now it's
it's a camera right about fat cam really
yeah
like so you lose weight is that what
it's for it's you you go no it's okay
you go and you literally get woken up at
six in the morning and you have to go
walking for three miles in in the dead
heat in the middle of the summer i went
in the berkshires with mostly jewish
kids not all jewish kids but wait wait i
was not even fast what is it not kidding
i was like cloaked as you don't tell
your kids you're going it doesn't say
like it doesn't say like fat camp on the
on the sign and spray paint when you go
through the it's like wellness camp but
it is fat camp it's fat camp you go it's
everyone's like everybody was fat well i
was like the thinnest i was one of the
thinnest kids but it was
some kids are obese and would they what
would they do would they like just
hundreds of kids i'm not kidding yeah i
went i'm not and they all knew that they
were there because they were overweight
oh yeah doesn't that do something to the
psyche of course of course yeah it's
more rhetorical but yeah yeah
does it does it
yeah yeah
listen i'll tell you all about it you
you eat very small meals very you you're
restricted and then you you you're not
going to believe that it's really crazy
you line up you would line up in your
bathing suit like on on the hills to get
weighed every saturday no and then you
would get weighed you would get weighed
where you ate talk about how sick that
is you got weighed in the mess hall
where you ate every day breakfast lunch
and dinner they would have scales
this doesn't matter that's where you got
weight yes it does not in this fight
what's fat camp call now i went to camp
kingsmont see if it's still over
kingsman it is still they weighed you in
front of everybody cam shane that's the
biggest one they weighed you in front of
everyone yeah well you got weight
everyone lined up to get weight so
people saw you getting weighed
i swear to god this is true
that's where i went kingsmont
wow it's called fit farm now they call
it the fifth farm
farm look at this they hired some pr
these kids aren't even overweight at all
oh my god i was not very heavy i'm
telling you i i blew up every summer i
got fatter and fatter because of this
yes
i'm telling you well they're coconuts
they're making it like as an active
fitness camp fitness is different than
go you're going we're shipping you away
well we did do sports all day but but
listen this is the thing every morning
and then you would go walking up and
down hills next to cows in the pasture
oh my god
they were like they were like these are
last years sounds like i'm being funny
but you would like i feel like we will
hold on to the trunks of the other
[ __ ]
of the other like you know kids and you
would just walk up and then sweat like
it was the dead of summer did you
and you would
mar you would like with all the other
kids in the camp walk up and down the
hills and like people would drive by and
it was mortifying how were they with all
fat kids so they were all better yeah
and they were all i felt like they were
all in like in programs in college you
know like
for you know stuff that you would have
done you know what i'm saying like
physical therapy oh yeah yeah yeah or
nutrition but i felt like every night
they probably went back to their their
bunks and like got high and drunk and
like made fun of that's what they do
what are they nice
[ __ ] that's what they do in the
movies they were nice so like it wasn't
like nobody was like abusing you or
anything like that but wait but wait
wait wait wait if you if your parents
had felt that you were fit to their
liking would you have gone to camp
or were they like jessica campbell
you're going through a fat game years i
went to camp for years but my parents
had a hard time with me
being heavy
because they had a lot of issues with
their own looks you know i came from
that from the way you looked from you
know appearance was important and they
cared about me they didn't you know i it
was a part a lot of it was they didn't
want me to make fun of they wanted me to
you know that was a lot of it wasn't
like they were they were sending you to
fat camp for them not you well i think
they were sending it to for me too to
help me and a partner but it didn't help
you it made it worse well they it's not
like they they did it to be me i think
they were doing it to help me and a part
of me wanted to go to you know i was a
teenager so i thought oh let me go away
for the summer well it must have been
and look good yeah and try to get
healthier and then i became friends with
people and i enjoyed it it wasn't like a
horrible experience i had fun yeah and i
was around nice people who accepted me
it's not like i wasn't popular in school
though right i guess had friends because
i was funny yeah i was going to say
you're like hilarious
when you were
great it wasn't good for me i'll tell
you that much it was not good because it
got me heavier and heavier and heavier
how so because i didn't learn anything
and then i would lose all this weight
quickly and then go right back to school
and gain it right back plus more
because it's not healthy so you go back
to school in september and be like would
you do something to do it oh my god it
was a great summer and it looked great
they were like no you didn't yeah
no wait when you were there at that age
though did you acknowledge it as fat
camp did you all the kids be like we're
at fat camp you know where we are yeah
we all knew we were in fact was there
anybody who wasn't fat at all like they
were noticeably skinny but they weren't
fat came because their parents thought
they were fat well that was me kind i
mean you weren't fat compared to them
would they take a shredded kid at least
i was like not i was athletic like i was
always played sports yeah i mean i
played tennis in co in high school and
lacrosse and volleyball but i was like
10. we know you're a lesbian
[Laughter]
tell us your lesbian without telling you
no i ate a lot of box i mean i was
but it's keto yeah yeah if you ate more
of that you'd be thinner because that
has no calories i mean i was also
molested in fat camp by a counselor but
that's the show yeah but i think i asked
for it because my classes were tight my
clothes were really tight so i think i
asked for it and what happened how they
molest you
um not they it wasn't like a gang bang
but um no it was a it was a counselor uh
i was like 14 and and a counselor uh
would hit on me this guy fred he was so
perverted but i didn't know it at the
time
look what you've done
i look like fred identify fred i want to
play fred in the movie
[Laughter]
i'll get you the part oh my god who's
gonna play you
i don't know maybe barney
wait
would they accept a ki a shredded kid
could you have match
jonah hill's new world
14 year old
wait
jonah hill in the movie that played the
girl oh precious yeah
gabriel day cinema gabriel everdeen
gabardine
city bay gabby could you imagine if
that's who played me
i'm sorry if the giggles are
camp i have a question will they would
they admit a shredded child like if you
if you were like if you were a child
that want to feel
skinny shredded
good about yourself like probably did
anyone ever get did they have like you
had to meet certain like you're like
yeah you can't you can't come in you you
you can't like did you have to be a
certain anyone could join even because
it was a fitness camp really right so if
a kid was in good shape would you get a
kid in good shape in there as well and
then you know who they were yeah i don't
think they would let in a kid who was
like really they would discriminate
i i don't think reverse yeah i don't i
don't think they would
i i just don't think i don't know how
that would work like if kid didn't have
wait to lose
how they would come in but
it was it was pretty crazy i mean the
whole thing was how long was it
well you could go for a month or two
months so you slept there but we also oh
yeah you stay in a bunk because there's
like camps where you go every day
no no no this was sleep away this was
like from the movies have you ever do
you know what i don't even know like
that's world is so foreign to me i've
never done that in my life
can you imagine going away for the
summer and just staying with friends oh
my god well i went away from six years
old
to 16. i was never ten years you just
went away from the state camp that's a
jewish thing
how how often do you see your family or
parents are you kidding me they come for
a visiting day they come once it's like
a prison it's amazing
it's amazing i couldn't wait to go away
i beg to go same kids every year though
so you kind of grew up with that well
you become i'm still friends with people
and the camps are beautiful
after three seasons you got in shape you
weren't allowed back in yeah if it works
if it's supposed to work why did you go
for 10 years no no no she wasn't always
up for 10 10 years i went to regular
cash okay okay for years and then i went
to fat camp when i was a teenager
because i i mean i did have issues i
always had issues with food because i
grew up in an environment where food was
it was very [ __ ] up thing in my house
yeah a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] with food
you know people grow up with alcoholism
with drug addiction the stuff in my
house with food stuff major food stuff
wow
there was restrictions we never had food
in the house you know it was like really
[ __ ] up with food okay
would you now if one of your daughters
was overweight would you ever send them
to the fat camp or never never and i
would never restrict food from them i i
will always have food in the house so
one of the biggest things we call it in
fasting now what we call it intermittent
fasting yeah i'll never do that i mean i
one of the biggest problems with me
growing up is my parents didn't have
junk food and all that [ __ ] in the house
you can't do that so you so you went
left for it you got it when you i took
it from my friend's house i would like
steal food for my friends houses or go
buy it in the store i would get it
everywhere else and binge on it so you
let the kids eat junk food now yeah so
they have it but you limit it for them i
limit it totally but i give it to them i
i you can't do that it's not a good idea
yeah not good yeah i know i i do that
too i do but i give too much because
like literally last halloween my
six-year-old daughter delighted i said
what do you want to go for halloween i
said she said a jar of nutella
my kids loved it
no but she really wanted that's what she
wants to be our halloween costume what's
the jar of nutella and i was like
why do you want and she's like it's my
favorite thing in the world so i was
like okay so now me and jazz we kind of
we give them
we almo like almost every day they can
have like a snack but it's very
limited it's like one pack of fruit
snacks or a little bit of nutella with
fruit or something like that but we
don't like try not to deprive them of it
you know we give them a little bit of
alcohol as well yeah yeah because you
don't want them as nutella was that like
a mind blowing like were you like maybe
i'm giving my child too much hazelnut
spread yes i thought that then i also
thought what an excellent idea for a
costume because no other kid every other
kid is going you know pocahontas is some
hack [ __ ] yeah like my kid's gonna
go as a nutella and then we dressed up
the 10 month old vile was the first only
she's three months all the time as a
vaccine card that is so
funny
people definitely do you know it's so
funny because my kids love nutella too
and we give we give isabella you know my
my six-year-old who's beautiful thank
you so much
of our kids are the same age our
daughters are the same age and we both
say the same thing
we both look at each other's kids like
when you look at your own kid you're
like oh my god like this place in the
heart and then you look at other
people's kids and they're beautiful and
great whatever but there's like there's
just a connection to your own child but
your child looks so much reminds me so
much of mine that we both feel this
connection they like
it's so interesting it's it's really
true they're very similar
looking and i can't explain it yeah the
only thing they differ is politically
yeah politically and and yours is a dyke
and mine is straight thank god yes i
don't want her to have to live the life
i have yeah she's a yeah
yeah she was um yeah my daughter my
sister
um she introduced me to her uh to her
girlfriend who's a he has a 45 year old
woman
yeah her friend and her your daughter's
girlfriend cries a lot and she's a crush
she's really angry and she she marches
everywhere um um i i
yeah it's a different thing now because
now i wonder if there'll be less and
less fat camps because now as parents
it's like who ca it's more about like
celebrate who you are like now if you go
to sports illustrated well the yeah uh
prevalence of obesity there's a lot of
fat kids out there 14.4 million uh uh
obese children but if you go to sports
illustrated pimpy right now on the cover
of sports illustrated there's big
controversy about a plus size um woman
uh who's on the cover sports illustrated
no if uh right now she's an asian woman
asian put in asian
yeah not kim kardashian it's sports
illustrated yeah
yeah so this so um go down a little i i
want to just get her name
um it's all over the internet now
because
jordan peterson retweeted this jordan
peterson he tweeted this woman saying
this i don't care what the authoritative
what authority says this isn't this
isn't sexy this is unhealthy that's what
he said about yeah
think that
you knew was her name i don't think
that's unhealthy you think not that is
not unhealthy that's a girl
that looks like it's unhealthy that's
not that's not unhealthy if you're 400
pounds it's unhealthy that's not
unhealthy not unhealthy no that's
actually sorry i what
yeah
yeah
wow
wow that's a choice
liz those yeah you never seen these
pants you never know oh yeah no how do
why would i have seen that well because
it's been that well because we're
wearing them on the next page
you're calling those pants i'm calling
them not pants like how are those pants
these are pants yeah mostly pants she's
i get body positivity but that is really
like i'm gonna that that is a little bit
like
more than bodybuilding that's a lie yeah
but like well that's like i don't know
i'm gonna force
i well then again i guess if you saw a
girl in a regular bikini on the beach
you're like oh european like she's doing
the same thing it's just that my thing
is like whatever people make their own
choices i mean the the the sports
illustrated model
that jordan peterson talked about that
she this woman is not unhealthy she's
just not your standard sports
illustrated skinny ripped girl but yeah
this girl is like that's not unhealthy
i'll tell you something
to me
that is much hotter than a very very
very skinny one like i would much rather
[ __ ] that woman yeah me too than a tiny
skinny little woman yes i agree second
yeah
i'd [ __ ] jordan peterson yeah yeah
yeah i was talking about i would rather
[ __ ] a ghost
than jordan peterson but i would
is that a thing no oh because that was
horrible what i just said he said sorry
not beautiful no amount of authoritarian
power well tolerance is going to change
that you know what he's just saying
she's beautiful she's her name is yummy
well well
yeah yummy you know and great bathing
suit
i i'm interested i'm sorry what is he
he's it's not unhealthy that's not
unhealthy she's not unhealthy looking no
that's not a i get that it's i get that
it's it's more weight than a normal
she's right could i beat her in a foot
race it's not unhealthy right
yeah i said could i beat her in a foot
race maybe but that's a meeting
had the lizzo thing though how do you
not how do you not if she's in the room
wearing those pants how do you not how
are you able to peel your eyes from
harassment
it's impossible it's an impossibility
you know
if your son or daughter
are standing there looking at her ass
it's a lot i'm sorry
if my kids are standing next to me
and there's that ass whether it's a man
or a woman's doesn't matter it's not
even about weight
yeah right if there was your entire ass
is showing yeah in public i believe this
is her new merch i believe the lizzo
pants yeah well we have vince go for hey
baby babe
we got to get them
we have these guys pants i would i'll
die no we're gonna do it i didn't do it
did it go up at the seller
just my skin tags on my ass cheeks
skin
skin tags they're warts
yeah i mean you know that's the person
that wants to be looked at i don't i
hide in the shop i don't want to be yeah
and listen you know it's it's tough
because it's like this thing now where
it's like
it's it's a balancing act i think
as parents where it's like you want
the kids to be accepting of everything
and and be in this world that changes so
quick but something sometimes it's just
too much like i don't want my kid to
strive to be 400 pounds well it's not
i'm healthy it's not even about looks
that's always been my thing i never
cared i don't care believe it or not i
don't care what people think about what
i look like yeah i'm weird
that way as a woman i don't care it's
more how i feel and my health it was
it's always about my health yeah so now
because when you were overweight you had
blood pressure issues cholesterol issues
yeah now you have no issues you feel
good and i was miserable i was more
depressed i didn't feel good like no
energy and i have children yeah so i
just had to get healthier that's how i
feel right now like people i've i've
lost some weight and people like oh
you're in shape in the gym but then i
went to the doctor high blood pressure
high cholesterol right because i was
like oh i want to look like big so i was
eating like a lot of red meat and
lifting more weights and all that and
then the doctor's like yeah all your
numbers are like through the roof
because you're eating like way too much
red meat you're taking creatine like
what are you you know how much red meat
were you eating i was eating like
literally dude i was eating first of all
steak every day every day i was eating
red meat every single just for mass yeah
i was trying i just was like you know
what i'll never be ripped so let me just
be i wanted to just be [ __ ] massive
and then and then i was lifting a lot in
the gym like getting a lot stronger all
that and then i was like and then i went
to the doctor and the doctor came in and
she was like we're thinking of putting
you on medication and i was like what
are you talking why because i'm so
jacked and she was
and she was like
she was like no she was like you know
you're you're 37 your blood pressure is
very high and your cholesterol is very
high and your blood sugar is teetering
at pre-diabetic she was like so i want
to ask have you been what's been your
diet like and i've been like steak all
day every day baby i eat meat and she
was like i was like you know because i
want to lift heavy in the gym and she
was like look she was like you know i'm
going to give you six weeks to change
your diet
but in those six weeks if you don't come
back with lower numbers i have no choice
but to put you on medication because
once as a man once you cross 40 which
you're getting close then you become
like a ticking time bomb and she's like
you have children and a family and all
that and i was like yeah and she was
like well you
forget about what you look like it's
about what's on the inside now yeah i
was like yeah how's it going yeah
and then so and so that was two weeks
ago and since then i've only had about
10 seconds
yeah i know you saw like two weeks ago
no that was two weeks ago and i missed
an appointment today listen sell you
know i got a house i got a lawn now i've
been using sunday lawn care i don't know
i didn't know anything about lawn i
don't know what chemicals you got to buy
a bunch of different things sunday lawn
care
if you got a lawn it just makes it like
simple if i can do it it's simple i've
been seeing actual commercials for them
on television basically it's a
subscription lawn service and they send
you all the stuff you need but people
are worried about chemicals you don't
have to worry about that no no because
there's they don't use harsh chemicals
uh yeah and you could just and you don't
have to go anywhere what the the coolest
thing that they have that i think is
that bag that you like hook up to the
hose yeah and then you just do like 15
minutes on the lawn that's it filters
through the bag and you literally
the lawn it's that's all you have to do
all these companies you don't have to
have a green thumb no sunday can i have
a green thumb regardless but that's
because of different things
i have a disease sunday can help you
grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals which
is important for me you know i got kids
in the house and it literally is just
you just attach the ready use pouch as
sal said garden hose and spray less than
15 minutes sunday is offering our
listeners 20
off full season plans start at just 129
and you can get 20
off at checkout when you visit get
sunday.com slash hey babe it's a steal
that's a steal and it's 20 off your
custom plan at getsunday.com
it really works try it
what do you want to eat tonight i want
to eat whatever's at my fingertips with
doordash the world is my oyster maybe
i'll have oysters maybe bro with your
dish i can have oysters if anybody's
going to deliver oysters to your door
it's door dash okay you can get drinks
snacks other household items in under an
hour they got 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood go to's or
choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
cheesecake factory what are you guys
going to order that right now i know you
are i like to support local but you can
also support anyone you want if you want
to support popeye you support popeye
it's easy your items are left safely
outside your door right it's the best
thing it's the most convenient thing
we're living in the future we live in
the future i pull up my phone i open
door dash i scroll through all the
restaurants in my neighborhood i hit a
couple of buttons i put it down my bell
rings that restaurant has food has come
to me via door dish i'm proud to be a
door dasher for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code hey babe that's
tell 25
off up to 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe sal did
you hear me i heard you and i used
doordash last night to order on on
garo's i'm gonna shout out on garrosh
some of the best pizza on staten island
can i tell you one more time please
don't forget that's code hey babe for 25
viente cinco percent off your first
order with doordash
right now go to it subject to change
terms apply of course of course they
apply
so i'm not saying yeah
but we'll see but i've been i've been
taking more fiber i've been taking um
i've been trying to eat better i've
tried tried to go a little bit vegan i'm
trying to eat more fish how do you do a
little bit yeah fish is good i just did
a little vegan i'll have like like today
like today i had egg whites and turkey
bacon and i had some lettuce on it
because it's just so it's a little bit
of vegan okay
so you're like a little you're a little
bit vegan a little bit i i go vegan and
keto one meal a day i go keto for one
meal well i just don't eat bread right
you know but i've been eating ezekiel
bread but even ezekiel bread which they
say is better i'd like to do what
jessica doesn't just eliminate bread all
together i know but like you know what's
good is brown rice cakes okay i eat them
i love brown rice cakes
rice cakes are amazing
they're good i swear you'll get used to
that so what do you put on a brown rice
cake to give it some flavor or not or do
you have that you can you can do a
little bit of cream cheese you can do
some hummus you can do um
you can put a lot of stuff on it i'm
serious you can even put like a little
bit of um like if you like almond butter
sure they told me sun butter's the best
though for people with high quality
butter's good but almond butter's not
bad sun butter i'm sure your kids do
this in school you'll see
you cannot have any type of nut butter
at all in any school in [ __ ] within a
mile of a school so people can't eat
butter
anyone you cannot have people you can't
bring peanut butter and jelly to school
if you eat it every day
peanut butter and jelly into my school
would be the same thing as bringing in a
gun they would shut the school down and
they would say there's a mass shooting
at your school somebody brought in a pb
and j's a penis shooter
are you serious it's like that now the
wheelchair get under the desk
i swear to god sun butter and jelly
nothing no nuts like my daughter's
birthday's on thursday peanut butter and
jelly every day for nine years well
you're a serial killer yeah you're a
mass murderer you're eating raw meat
every day no sun butter and jelly is the
only acceptable thing what is sun butter
i think it's is it is it sunflower seeds
i think so oh yeah yeah yeah
but chris have brown rice i'm gonna send
you the picture of what i eat brown rice
cakes with i have it with egg whites in
the morning i brought egg whites with
vegetables
cheese that's what you do a little bit
of feta cheese in the egg whites oatmeal
oatmeal yeah that's too much but oatmeal
i don't eat oatmeal because i don't want
too much of it okay because i can't
control myself because you have that
good joke you're like oh oatmeal and
brown sugar it's like yeah
you're making me a pie you ate a pumpkin
six cups of brown sugar in it yeah
i i try to i'm trying to eat a lot more
cinnamon like today or yesterday i had
oatmeal cold oatmeal that i made then
before with cinnamon and that's
delicious and try to do that in some
almond milk cinnamon and i think
cinnamon is good right free greek yogurt
is delicious yeah yeah yeah fat free
greek 0 it's not bad that faji greek
yogurt is still nothing
yeah it's still shout out
shout out to greeks yeah greek yogurt is
delicious yeah i actually we have it all
the time yeah yeah with fruit but if you
have the greek yogurt with all the other
stuff in it then it's no good you can
have some almonds in it or and and some
walnuts are very nuts yup and fruit and
a little bit of honey it's delicious can
i tell you what she tries to do though
she drinks so hungry right now
i'm starving
i i'm gonna eat like so much nut sun sun
nuts whatever i i show nuts she she she
tries to pass off greek yogurt to sour
cream
that's what i know i might have
we have sour cream she's like we have
greek yogurt i'm like it's not the same
thing no it's the exact same thing
it's not it's white no
creme fresh is pretty good it is
delicious what's
yogurt is but what about non-fat is it
non-fat old stuff all bad for you too
like non-fat sour cream is that bad for
you what about greek sour cream
i've never had that but i but what about
non-fat greek sour cream yogurt yeah
what about sour greeks
what about creamy greeks oh creamy
greeks nice
shout out grinder
um
you know what else too shout out grinder
grinder if you're watching and we know
that you all
yeah i mean i think i think you you
throw up you make a grinder profile okay
is that is that a smash hit right away
if i made a grinder profile he did yeah
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's gonna be
good kill it yeah why don't we make one
and see what comments he gets i'd like
to do that yeah but you're gonna catch
me do that i'd like to make a grinder
profile absolutely yeah you're gonna
catfish these sweet gay men i want to
keep experimenting absolutely absolutely
i can because because um
honestly i've put up three grinders and
see
and see who gets like let's see who gets
the most numbers you guys would all get
all three of you would do very well we
should actually go all three as one
account we should share one account be
like it's three guys one grinder
yeah he wears twill pants yes joe derosa
just dresses fashionable and there's
something gay men like men with uh dirty
shoulders
[Laughter]
i love him so much um he's adorable you
like joe derosa i'm in love with him
yeah i've always loved you well i love
one as much as i love you guys i would
say out of all of us he's the one that
looks most like a lesbian
he does like he could seamlessly
multiple lesbian features yeah 100
um i'd love to see derose at fat camp
yeah being a counselor you know what
derozan did during his summers i'm not
joking he there was a ditch there was a
big ditch outside of his house and he
had no friends and he would go sit in
the ditch and play in the ditch alone
outside of his house
why we've talked about this at length
he it was his ditch
interesting right am i did i get that
sounds like did i miss quotes
he's yeah that's what it was the other
kids were like we don't associate with
you we know the truth about you
it's the best ditch
so um
but here's the thing with you know he
loved the ditch though here's the thing
that's got to be hard with you because
of how
successful you are at not only on stage
but also now off stage with transforming
your body and and not having a piece of
bread in six months but your manager
bakes bread so how do you deal with that
at meetings when he's coming in and he
gets a lot i i ate it when he when he
first started um
baking it it's delicious what is his
instagram jim serpico's
jim serpico who we all know who's a
friend of the show side hustle side
hustle bread
go follow that instagram and go back
amazing it's delicious honestly it's
incredible
artisanal bread outside
got into a bread he makes no ch look at
the spread jim sharpico makes some of
the best bread and look yeah there there
he is yeah see i get oh this is his son
uh just graduating from ufc look at that
ufc ufc ufc
yeah look and he and and it's delicious
and he has a new podcast too called
bread for the people bread for the
people it's great how do you get into
that there you go
listen to the podcasts eat the bread
speak in a podcast you and i had oh god
can
listen i just had someone again last
week okay send me a message that said
anytime i'm in i'm sad yes or going
through a hard time i listen to your
relatively sane podcast with chris
destefano you
when you use
i was sent a video of you sal you once
on a plane listening to me and jessica
talk
on the podcast and you were crying oh
yeah laughing because i think what
happened was it was one of those moments
in pot it's not even so much that what
we were saying was so funny is just we
were having so much fun
and dying like that
i think it's infectious yeah yeah
chris and i
did it a podcast episode you pull it up
yeah yeah we laughed i was on a plane
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
i
we have to find it
no i don't think the video of me
laughing at it it is no the video of me
i got sent out privately
google christos stefano jessica kirsten
relatively relative relatively sane
relatively sane is that the one that i
did all the carrot is yeah the
characters and things yeah this is it
yeah um 85 yeah so um but i don't know
if that wasn't it no this oh is that
with bill burr no there was one you and
i didn't know no it's with chris with
chris no but you didn't even just you
didn't even film this this was just
audio remember i would you were it was
no it's audio no but it was the infancy
of your podcast
though it's on there wow
yeah i don't know definitely on there
because people listen to it but if you
listen to it if you hear it go just
google krista stefano relatively sane
podcast uh jessica here said it the
first thing it literally was
i remember still to this day
like not being able to breathe how hard
we were laughing because we were making
up [ __ ] stories
it's definitely definitely uh
put in d-i-s okay there you go yeah and
this came out in 2021 but we filmed it
like a year before that this was so long
ago no we filmed it even before that but
that is that yeah that's it that's it
okay so there you go and then and then
right after that is pete holmes if
there you go
crashing i never got on the show did you
ever get on a show
crashing yeah i was on it a bunch of
times i was the only i got cancelled
right when i started getting on it all
the time they're like the show's
cancelled i'm like you weren't on that
no i was i felt like i was one of the
only comics to not get on even mo ammer
went on the show got on the show
crashing and he lit and my friends used
to make fun of me because they were like
oh everyone's on crashing but you and
then mo ammer came to my house
came to stay with me for three weeks
because he was didn't want to get a
hotel he's coming from houston he was
legitimately sleeping on my couch and
then one day he left at like six o'clock
in the morning came back at like nine
o'clock at night and i was like where
were you he was like i got on crashing i
was like even the guy's sleeping on my
couch
i never got on it you never got on it
now that happens to me a lot with stuff
where people
isn't that the worst everyone gets on
something i even auditioned for a part
what yes i don't know if he knew i don't
i don't really know pete but i
auditioned for uh an uh artie lang
overzealous
uh fan and uh i see him with already
lang or whatever
who's my friend too i don't know and i i
went and i auditioned and then
is it lying around what's happening no
arnie lange i don't know he stopped his
podcast a few months ago he did i don't
know yeah i don't have him
i don't know what's going what's going
on with artie if you're listening
already and we know that you are yeah um
we hope that uh we hope that you're well
i mean i just did yeah uh on saturday i
just did the count
basie center theater whatever i did it
with him once so i opened for him once
so did i i opened that and that's why it
came full circle because i opened for
him there in 2011 and it was the first
time i'd ever stepped foot on a theater
ever in my life so i was like wow and he
was like just do five minutes and i
remember you know because this time i
did it on my own and i remember like
feeling how many people it looks like
and all that and i literally had like
five minutes of material he let me open
for him and i'm talking about the second
i pulled the mic out of the stand in
2011 because you know it's crazy howard
stern audi lang fans i was wearing a
purple flannel shirt and somebody from
like the back deck was like nice shirt
homo and it killed and you couldn't tell
and i couldn't get back from it and i
[ __ ] bombed so hard oh my three and a
half minutes in audie lang came on the
voice of god mike and was like i'll be
out in just a minute guys
give chris a chance
and then i tried like one more bit and
it [ __ ] got a zero and i brought out
artie
and and and that was you know whatever
look babes let's talk about lucy we're
adults here we could talk about lucy yes
i got my my stepmom i sent her some lucy
and she's using it now as an alternative
to smoking we're all adults here i know
some of you will choose to use nicotine
maybe you want to relax focus unwind
after a long day people are going to do
nicotine i sound like an old person you
do you're doing nicotine nicotine uh
lucy is a modern oral nicotine company
you said oral that makes i did say it
that makes nicotine gum they make
lozenges and pouches for adults that are
looking for the best most responsible
way to consume nicotine it's a new year
why not start out by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about i love nicotine i mean i mean i
love lucy
i don't want nicotine it's a nicotine
alternative if you enjoy using nicotine
you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy dot co
that's lucy.co
and use promo code babe
at checkout also i have to read the
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine
visit lucy.co and be sure to use that
promo code
babe
you know me
babel
i see i do
i love learning new languages you know i
learned c how
long ago for my grandparents but you
know what you can learn c if you don't
know what it meant babel language
learning app language learning number
four
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
all these other companies they're all
doing ai technology
not babel okay
they actually have language learning
experts that come together over 100 of
them to make this app and they use
speech recognition technology which
helps you improve the pronunciation and
accent that's key it's also not like how
you used to learn when you were in
school it's not just like repetition
it's like a fun way to learn the lessons
are fun uh and they have been proven
scientifically to be effective you start
picking stuff up right away they have
you know
14 languages you know all the hits but
the thing is guys if you're looking to
maybe learn a new language you always
want to or you never considered it but
now we're talking about you consider it
you can do it you know
on your on your commute in the morning
you could do it at lunch you could do it
sitting in the park you just open the
app little by little chip away at it
learn a new language
[Laughter]
well really
plus it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
you could
right now you could save up to 60 of
your subscription when you go to
babble.com hey babe that's b-a-b-b-l
dot com
slash hey babe for up to 60 of your
subscription b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash hey babe secretary of your
subscription language for life yes start
your journey now babes
but that's amazing but i remember being
on the stage you know a couple of days
ago being like oh wow like this is it's
been a long journey but the same guy
yelled the same thing to me from the
upper deck we were just there saturday i
was just there saturday and then my
father yelled nice shirt home on the
front row
i just said you should've wore that
purple shirt oh my god there's no way
i'd fit into it with how fat i got i
need camp
that's what i want to talk about this is
big news
right now
what what is the us the u.s intelligence
congress actual real congress now
held a hearing today about ufos like
it's going to get to the point where
like now
that you can't hide it anymore because
now actual congress like we have to get
involved there's been over 400 incidents
it says 140 but i wanted to make it 400
for the podcast 400 incidents of ufo
signings now a lot of people are saying
some of it might be u.s intelligence
some of it might be you know chinese
intelligence russian intelligence but
and a lot of those are being mentioned
by the u.s congress they're saying yes
some of this could be enemy aircraft
just because we say ufo doesn't mean
it's aliens could unidentify flying
object could be china could be whatever
but they're saying oh that's not real
there aren't there are at least 10 of
them that every
country is saying like there's not like
we promise you that's not ours you know
wait now what prompted this today
uh well i think it's been on the books
for for a little bit right people do you
have the answers years of like leaked
military footage and the military's
like afraid of it
yeah because i think what's happened
with the internet is you can't keep it
you can't keep the lid on it anymore
right right right you used to be able to
but now it's like too many videos go out
and also like lucas the mars rover found
like a doorway on mars
this is a screenshot of that that in no
way shape or form could be real you
don't think that's real that's it looks
so fake i mean they they just understand
what that is they're saying that there's
like a fun construct no what is that
what is that so that's on mars they're
saying there's a door that uh a rover a
a a a uh like a mars rover you know we
have like machines on mars they found a
doorway they're saying a door has been
found on mars they're saying and uh i
mean i'm sure skeptics are already
debunking it right or are they saying
that there is a door
who the hell knows the rover took a
photo well listen i mean if the galaxies
are billions and billions and billions
of years old who knows if mars used to
be in this goldilocks zone that we're in
now and there was a whole life there
goldilocks zone
that's what we're in the goldilocks zone
really i never heard that that's the
term that they use for the exact
condition right conditions for what
earth is in now
proximity from the sun you know fresh
water it's called the goldilocks zone
and that's what they go into different
parts of the universe different galaxies
to look for the goldilocks zone in
different places i think we need to
heard that throw them back into the food
chain so i hope there's aliens you want
to get eaten you're saying i think we
need to have fear of something that's
not the internet
right
well that's yeah
yeah i live in fear of so much already
why would i want to live in fear of
aliens
that's why i have jasmine i live in fear
of her
you know what's crazy it's like
she's your she's yours she's she's my
yeah she's my she's my fear she's my
food chain
sometimes i just wake up and she's
covered me in adobo and she's got a
knife
[Laughter]
yeah it was actually you know what we
did last night which is like crazy like
i was thinking about this like if my
mother if we did this in front of my
mother she would lose her mind so we
went out yesterday with
you know me jazz and this other couple
and they have their daughter goes to my
daughter's school so we went out for
pizza at four o'clock shout out sepe's
great pizza on staten island if you guys
ever looking for good pizzerian staten
island shout out to setbacks great pizza
and so we go there four o'clock right
and then we're eating done shout out
four o'clock shout out four p.m what a
great time of day it doesn't no one
i would say four o'clock is our
goldilocks zone you're right it's like
it's like late afternoon early
but evening you're an hour away from
going home you probably took your
afternoon [ __ ] you're getting hungry
again you're looking at this
stuff the runway in the daylight is
still yeah on the secretary anything
everything
420 420 is it 20 minutes away from four
o'clock yeah it's perfect time
so
so four o'clock so we're finished
whatever maybe 5 15 5 30. i get a
parking ticket which i always do and
then and then we're going into the car
and the couple were with they were like
they only live a couple blocks away from
us like why don't you just let the girls
play like let them play for an hour or
two and then whatever we'll leave at
seven
we hung out on a school night and both
our kids are in school right now we hung
out to midnight last night
drinking having fun the kids were up the
girls were going crazy where
in my house oh okay because we just made
a choice where we were like
we're all parents we're like you know
they're having so much fun like they
don't have homework they had actually
the day they had no school yesterday for
some parent-teacher conference [ __ ]
i don't even know what i paid for i mean
these kids [ __ ] never go to school
but but i but i i i was like you know
what like whatever and it was like we'll
wake up
this morning if they're if they're
throwing a fit and they're exhausted
then whatever like we'll give him a day
off it's fine
but then they woke up today delilah
up today and we heard the other guy
daughter woke up today like so freaking
excited to tell their friends like the
play date they had and then we checked
in i called before the podcast just to
make sure because we let the teacher
know like hey they were up a little late
last night she's like no she's up she's
telling everybody she's having like the
best day so i was like i'm not gonna
make that a habit but i think you know
what you said about parenting before
where it's like you know if you keep
things from them like everything with me
with my mom was so regimented and you
have to be in bed and yeah and it was i
was so nervous all the time yeah where
like now it's like with my kids i'm just
very much like you know what once in a
while them having a day that's out of
the ordinary it's fine if they're not in
bed at 7 30 it's fine because she woke
up today like full of life and it was
great everyone's scared to throw off the
sleep schedule yeah
i was like you know what i'm not going
to live my life like that i'm going to
get drunk on a school night you you you
and i texted her you tell the parents
that's good
the teacher yeah i was drunk texting her
last night did you tell the teacher yeah
what i'm saying that's it that's
dangerous like yeah you tell me
[Laughter]
correct i love them for you
i need to have a conference right now i
need to have a media parent teach a
conference yeah why don't you teach the
truth that the aliens made this fix
i can't believe that you tell the
teacher i got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
deserved it
[Laughter]
i can't believe you talked to a teacher
that way like even even like even like
mike my daughter stayed up a little late
last night my parents did not come in
contact with my teacher ever ever no
it's a different world
i just showed up with my hair looking
like my
if you ask my father right now what
school did chris go to you would have no
idea
my mother knows but my dad would be like
i don't know i forgot i can't believe
that she went to school can you imagine
like my mom like calling on the landline
a t-shirt be like sal will be in a
little while he stayed up a little late
last night it sounds mind-blowing
no they
you there's an app there's an app that
all the parents are on like what like
the the message we sent to the teacher
it's all the parents on twitter is that
is that good is it pros and cons well it
i'm telling you it is good it is good
but you hear like the lines
here here's a perfect example
everybody's in everybody's business did
something has too much information too
much well being too connected is not
it's got pros and cons yeah the pros are
it's good you know it's everything going
on but like one of not not this year's
teacher but the other school my daughter
went to
their teacher was like a 25 year old
fresh out of college girl whatever and
parent-teacher conference whatever you
end at like say that you get the
teachers get out out of 12 30. and they
went and had like drinks at like three
o'clock and posted on their instagram
they were like just getting drunk at a
local bar and the parents were like in
an uproar i'm like this is who we're
teaching our daughters i'm like yes
she's a 25 year old girl that
has a long three-day weekend
what do you want her to do go back into
the school and
keep refreshing les i want her to get
drunk and start doing some blow because
that's what she's a normal person yeah
and that's teaching my kid that's crazy
because when we were younger you did if
you spotted your teacher i went to
catholic school same so like i we had
the uniform and they had to dress a
certain way so like if you ever spotted
a teacher out in the wild like at the
mall or at a gas station they weren't
like street clothes you couldn't even
believe it you were just like because
you saw teachers for like
i went to the same school for nine years
so almost all of a sudden i caught a
first grade teacher like the mall and
she was in like sweats or something
couldn't believe it we couldn't even
believe it because you just don't you
don't associate that they have a real
life that they're anything but what they
are yeah yeah if i saw a teacher of mine
when i was little just getting hammered
in a bar no
well i mean yeah that's the thing it's
like you know because these people you
know post their lives on instagram and
again for me i was one of the only me
and jazz one of the only parents that
had no issue with this at all but these
old school parents they were like wanted
to have her written up and talked to the
prince i'm like for what because she's
having a drink like so i was like i'm on
the phone with you on the forum
were you where were you having this
discussion with them like you were
defending this little teacher yeah well
well it's like an app that you it's
called like group me or group you or
something what ended up coming over did
you prevail well see that's the thing is
like as far as like i was like i was
kind of telling jazz what to say i was
like respond with this and we were
having but so really but like a lot of
the parents that's the thing with people
if somebody just says something against
the grain then you start to see like one
by one people start to fall and be like
maybe i over thought it or whatever but
then you know you have the people who
are annoying who like the per the parent
who was being the most annoying about
this of course their kid is allergic to
every [ __ ] not known
even the nut allergies i believe to a
point i'm like i don't think everybody
has nut allergies here i think some of
your parents are nuts yeah and they and
they and they want you to have an
allergy because there's like this
narcissism in them where they're like
look at how many problems my kid has and
what they have to overcome it's like
just what i think some of them have
anxiety disorders
i think some of them have major
anxieties you know 90 of food allergies
are not are not food allergies they're
mental they're the kid will still get
the allergy where they feel as if they
can't breathe and they feel as if
they're getting itchy but biologically
they're not some 10 truthfully is
closing your airways and that needs to
be dealt with but 90
are are psychosomatic really meaning the
kid is not again the kid really feels it
so you have to treat them and not have
the nuts around them but it's not a you
know because they have testing now you
go to an allergist they can test you and
say this is what you're allergic to
because they can see it on your skin or
if they reproduce but how is it kid
having a reaction to something that he
doesn't know he not because he or she
or they
probably think that they're having some
type of breathing reaction or some type
of anaphylactic shock because maybe some
condition in their household or their
parents think they do or whatever but
they actually don't and then it triggers
it every time they know but then they're
on medication for it and and they might
as well have it anyway but i'm saying
like they don't go because i think to go
through the proper like for example you
could eat a peanut or your kid could eat
a peanut and be like oh i can't i feel
like i can't breathe right away the
doctor's like you have a peanut allergy
keep it away they don't but to go
through the next levels of testing and
this and that right is another step that
a lot of parents don't take because you
may test it and be like you actually
don't have an allergy so just eat the
peanut and it's fine are you allergic to
anything
um are you allergic to anything i'm only
the only thing i know i'm allergic to is
is sofa drugs like i it's just a
medication okay but i don't think i've
ever left i don't think i'm allergic to
anything i thought i was allergic to
fake plants and cats but i i don't think
i am
and i have allergies like from pollen
and stuff like that oh yeah
seasonal allergies and depression
[Laughter]
seasonal depression seasonal depression
every changing of the seasons every time
every equinox i get violently depressed
every equinox i start to slowly put a
noose on my neck
i wonder if i do even going into summer
yeah fall equinox is the worst
wow yeah
really yep are you using all equinoxes
depression or exotic you have exotic
more anxiety
i have both
pick one no anxiety well don't they go
hand in hand
yeah but i do what do i have more of you
it's anxiety isn't it
i have anxiety but not as bad as i did
anymore no i'm not depressed yeah but i
don't
i got i got both and i got them good
you know
having children took me out of my
anxiety a little bit i guess anxiety i
guess more anxious anxiety is better
than it used to be it's way better now
because my life because it's not about
me anymore like there's something
outside of myself so now it's like i
feel like i can't be this nervous and
this paralyzed with fear
since the kids
well you have four kids yeah you have
four daughters yeah yeah that's crazy
but staying busy with business stuff
helps right when i like that's why kovid
was like i mean for so many reasons but
like not traveling and being home all
the time oh my god that was hard that
was right yeah not having that to focus
on yeah i was doing good myself like
yeah oh that was tough for what's the
age ranges
um the youngest twins are going to be
three june 10s
and the oldest is going to be 16. right
wow
yeah yeah and she's an actress she's the
one that sings yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's amazing is she
what what and the 16 that is a sweeping
age range right well the first zoe is
with my ex sherry and then
the next three are with my current
danielle yeah yeah yeah here we go
courtney dilla courtney uh to dilla
courtney
is ranked she looks like jasmine is
ranking in the big bucks quadrupling her
teacher salary he's not facing you yeah
that i know that's why cause jasmine
um but but she's she's gotten only fans
that is um raking in a lot of money now
here's the thing with only fans is i
honestly don't mind it i don't look down
upon it i think
here's the thing and this is good to
have you on uh is
with feminism right what if it's all
about feminism which i have i have two
daughters so i'm like go be a you know
feminism all about women whatever
it should be okay if if i want to pay if
i'm a horny guy and i want to pay for
courtney tita to shake her ass what is
the problem with that there's no problem
with that it's fine just like
prostitution should be legal because
whatever so what if the woman's body's
so powerful i have a problem you know
i'm just saying there are people out
there that have problems with this and
i'm like you can't be a feminist and
also have a problem with that
i i that's the rub though that's it's i
don't get it either i don't either like
it's that's what it's her choices
that have issues with that but then are
feminists
the only fans are some people say it's
empowerment and some people you know
like with the wizards well they're
haters because it's like so what you
know like the cash me outside girl makes
like 50 million i'm curious what what
are what if someone has a problem with
it what's their problem with that it's
like
showing women like giving women a bad
black eye or or her choice you know it's
her body her choice that's what i'm
saying yeah that's that's what i was
shouting it's her body her choice yeah
to do what she wants with her body
would you join brett kavanaugh's only
fans if he were getting killed
free in abundance in perpetuity
pornhub or something like why would you
pay because i think they specifically
want to see
certain people on it yeah but you could
look at if you like one specific
porn star you could also just look at i
don't know i don't see the i don't see
it
listen
tt jerry who's who's been on this
podcast who guest hosted once
is you know family member of mine
transgender
she wants to start and only fans and
people are trying to talk her out of it
i'm like
go do it yeah what's the problem i have
a friend who started doing it yeah
and
she
sells pictures of her she has
enormous breasts enormous and they're
real i'm talking i've never seen
real boobs yeah
and she sells pictures of her ass and
her [ __ ]
and people pay thousands of dollars it'd
be funny if one tier is asked once
you're his [ __ ] so much money
and there's never
five dollars
five dollars for ass 50 thousand people
but but
and there's never a picture of like the
face next to the whole so she think no
one could ever prove and her boobs and
everything are out she puts everything
out yeah i'm not kidding she makes she's
making ten thou like it's crazy how much
money and i'm like you know what i will
[ __ ] it but no i will name it there's a
podcast producer on a very famous
podcast
versus comic who's making a ton of yeah
and then she she left
she left the podcast she's making more
money than the podcast hosts and the
podcast hosts are making millions of
dollars i i know and she made more money
in two months she was like i'm out of
here
who's
i'll tell you well well i don't know i
don't know if it's possible
a few times but is it public though uh
she she left yesterday i don't know did
she yeah from the pod but i don't want
to
can we confirm it i don't want to then
i don't know tell me your favorite baby
yeah i'll tell you because i i think she
might but everybody on there is showing
hole
no no no no
there's there's
female comics who show hole
whole
yeah i did not realize that yeah
when i've been on shows with i'm like oh
my god i've seen her whole like it's so
but they pay so much money like it's
uncomfortable for me because i'm a even
though i'm a lesbian and i'm like i am
very sexual
it's still like for guys i think it's
maybe it's not different
do you feel different with what when
you're on a show with a comic then
you've seen her vagina
is it weird not someone you've been with
not someone you say you've been with
someone it's not that if you've seen
like porn of them or an only face oh
yeah because there's a couple of ports
that do comedy it's not weird but i will
that's all i think about it
with them
what
i'm saying like the couple of points are
that that come and do comments
yeah i just think about the porn scenes
with them i don't think about like when
i've been on a show with them i'm like
i've picture that that's all i can think
about right
yeah but i think the thing is the
argument is like
is this okay it's not like if you're one
of your daughters was like having only
one seven only fans when they're out of
age or whatever would you have an issue
with that yes no but that might be no
that might be a thing that we have to
deal with accept them no matter what
because that's who i am
would i be happy about it no see that's
that's the little weird line it's like
body choice but then it's also like you
still like i wish they don't so it's
like it's not i know but
that's the whole thing
it's like i don't want you know but how
do you guys feel about the naked roasts
have you been to those oh yeah those
naked roasts that's brutal that's brutal
i've been to them it's brutal do you get
paid for that or they just naked
roasting i i've not seen someone get
paid but also being naked for like i
even if it was an only fans of a very
beautiful
woman let's say i wouldn't want to pay
for them just to be walking around naked
like i'd rather just see a a picture i
know
like i don't want to see anyone naked
for a period of time that's why the
naked rose bothered me because i'm like
i know it's too long like i don't need
to see your entire body for an hour
that's not what anybody wants yeah even
beautiful people it's like naked for
this long is not good yeah it's bad
naked it's bad naked and everybody
starts to look bad naked even the most
beautiful people in the world it's like
yeah i just want to see it in glimpses
you know it only takes me a few seconds
to come i also think you guys are
overlooking you got the good years on
earth most the kids can't socialize so
maybe only fans might be stopping mass
shooters
well i feel like we've had most more
mass shootings i feel like since the
world's opened up again we are [ __ ]
right back to the mass shootings that's
good yeah
i i'd like to see a comedian come out
and start shooting the audience
oh my god
if they don't get laughed
[Laughter]
i could think of a few who would do it
it would just come out oh i could think
i can think of a lot
of [ __ ] crap where i'm just where can
people find you where are you going to
be next what's what's next oh well i
have a bunch of dates coming out on
thursday this episode oh cool so i'll be
in san diego this weekend um at mic drop
comedy club and then i'm going to be in
uh florida i have a bunch of shows
coming up all over
i'll be if you can just check out my
website jessicacarson.com join my tick
talk i post crowd work videos every day
on tick tock hilarious and thank you and
i'm an instagram at jessie kirsten i
love you guys so much
you're you know i adore you too
i i love you guys
and um i made you and i may join only
fans and start [ __ ] my face with
chips amazing because i yeah honestly
people would pay for that i know i think
so for you to start eating bread again
people would pay for my face with food
because i don't chew
when i eat so i might just start
slamming food down my face
just [ __ ] face [ __ ]
you just see your pita bread on your
tits
all right and up for me christy
comedy.com next week i am in may 24th
the vulcan in austin may 26th stand up
live in phoenix tickets almost gone for
both of those and then i got nothing
until july um which i'll be at the
comedy connection uh in july uh first
week of july go to christycomedy.com and
of course especially wesh you on netflix
now streaming uh this weekend i am at
san diego on the 21st saturday i am in
la at the wilton on sunday and then
right this second the pre-sale is up for
vegas
phoenix
boulder colorado seattle portland and
vancouver and something else it's all
right now the promo codes god bless
[Music]
don't be savilecanoncomedy.com don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey